all right finally this video went viral
I don't know where or when it was taken
but it's apparently from from the way
it's being described it's apparently
vegan activists somewhere who uh are
protesting a slaughterhouse and their
way of protesting slaughterhouse is to
try to stop a truck from going into the
slaughterhouse they're saying that the
the truck has uh animals in it that are
being brought into their demise and so
they want to stop this huge
truck from going in and they have their
way of attempting to do that which
doesn't work out spoiler alert doesn't
work out too well for them but uh here's
a video
standing here in front of a fearman
slaughterhouse where 10 000 lives are
taken daily ten thousand innocent lives
slaughtered here for no more than the
taste buds of humankind of humans
here we have the truck approaching we're
approximately 300 animals are stacked
into this truck
the softest truck so we can bear Witness
[Applause]
foreign
human life no respect for animal life
Psychopaths
jeez what is wrong with that guy what is
I I I'm shell shocked as I I almost got
hurt when I threw myself in front of a
truck
how could that have happened wow jeez
what exactly they are not setting their
best the vegans aren't I don't know if
it's because they're not getting enough
protein in their diet so their brains
are atrophying a little bit uh that's
that does happen that's science so I
don't know if that's what maybe that is
maybe this is their best that's the
thing I keep seeing vegan activists and
the stunts that they pull and uh and and
I always assume well this can't be their
best but I think the reality is that
this is this is the best they got so
what exactly was the plan it's you we
see at the beginning that there are
people
on the sides of this uh huge big rig and
they're holding on to the sides of it as
if they think that through that just by
holding it they can stop it from moving
and the truck keeps going and then they
try to throw themselves in front of the
truck and the truck continues on its way
and I don't think the truck actually did
run anybody anybody over
uh thankfully for the vegans
but if you have that would have been
their fault you throw yourself in front
of a truck
that's on you
and by the way you know when you've got
even if they are uh a bunch of noodly
armed vegans even so when you have
people uh mobs of people trying to stop
your car in the middle of the road
um you the safest thing is to keep going
because we've seen what happens in the
past when you stop for these people you
get pulled out of the truck you never
know what will happen
so for your own safety
and also for the safety of that of that
precious cargo in the back
on its way to the slaughterhouse
and for all the the rest of the sake of
all the rest of us who want to enjoy
that delicious bacon you have no choice
but to continue going
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]